ok tout le monde on prend une grande
respiration dans ce qu réguler ensemble
et je vais vous poser une question en
fait pour commencer donc ça va vous
demander d'être sur la même fréquence
que moi et vous allez comprendre
comment ça se passe votre relation avec
l'environnement les milieux naturels la
nature peu importe comme on l'appelle et
vous en bons termes ou c'est compliqué
avoue déjà penser à soi même là ça fait
deux questions je m'excuse
mais en fait ça fait depuis environ sept
ans que je réfléchi à cette question là
en fait je vais le dire le je suis
obsédé par cette question le donc
j'invite à visualiser une version moi
qui s'éteint on est dans le boisé en
arrière de chez moi j'observe les
animaux je prends conscience des
couleurs des textures de toutes les
sondes de les odeurs qui anime la nature
en fait ici j'ai commencé à créer des
liens avec le monde mais aussi des liens
avec moi même
puis un jour ce boisé la a été
complètement rasé les animaux sont
disparu pour laisser place à des maisons
qui a peu de gens peuvent se payer en
fait
je me souviens que un arbre en
particulier lorsque je les ai vus si
creusot ce
j'ai senti comme une douleur vive dans
mon ventre
ça m'a pris plusieurs minutes me calmer
c'est seulement treize ans plus tard que
j'ai compris que ce que j'avais vécu on
appelle ça une éco émotion une écurie
motion c'est tout simplement une émotion
qui témoigne de notre relation à notre
milieu de vie à notre environnement
parce que quand vient le temps
d'exprimer comment ça ne fait santé
d'avoir l'impression que notre futur se
dégrade à mesure qu'on avance
on manque cruellement de vocabulaire
heureusement des gens qui ont vécu des
expériences similaires à l'amiante ont
décidé d'inventer ces mots parce que
comment on veut comprendre une réalité
qu'on comprend pas d'abord à l'intérieur
de soi
vous comprendre de quoi je parle je vous
invite à vous replonger dans un souvenir
où vous êtes senti peut être angoissé
déconnecté endeuillées ou moins en
colère face à une situation
environnementale
essayez de vous re applique qu est-ce
que vos sens captait comme information
et commence sur sa se transformer en une
sensation une tension dans votre corps
qu'on nomme souvent une éco une nation
ou une émotion
puis comment cette sensation là en fait
un message important pour vous pour la
suite de votre histoire
insuffisamment ne tous nos sensibilités
face à ce qui se passe dans le monde
certains sites voire des injustices
envers les vivants
d'autres ont carrément vécu des traumas
vironnement tôt comme le développement
de mines qui ont dû quitter leur
domicile
puis certaines personnes qui essaient
tout banal à chaque fois qu'ils sortent
leur recyclage ils sont complètement
découragé devant la quantité de matières
résiduelles nécessaire pour soutenir une
mode de vie
collectivement on vit aussi des échos
émotions qui façonnent d'ailleurs notre
passé notre présent puis mais notre
futur si je vous dis fait fort et en
australie qu'est ce que ça vous rappelle
comme sentiment
si je vous dis pandémie mondiale
qu'est-ce qui vous habite présentement
si je vous dis
new york sous l'eau
puisque ça évoque comme penser qu'une
sensation
on vit ces choses là au quotidien puis
on s'en parle pas assez pour ma part ce
premier sentiment de colère de tristesse
puis deux jambes j'ai vu l'arbre tombé
ça a été le point de départ en fait de
mon engagement envers le vivant
que ce soit mes études en écologie en
environnement mon implication comme
coordonnatrice du mouvement militant
pour le climat ici à sherbrooke ou
encore la création d'une entreprise
collective nommé commotion qui s'est
spécialisé dans l'accompagnement des
échos émotions parce qu'à sept ans sans
savoir me s'embarquer dans un long
voyage
celui de comprendre le rôle de nos
émotions dans notre adaptation en face à
un monde en grand changement j'aimerais
vous invite à bord de ce voyage pendant
quelques minutes
mais avant notre départ
j'ai une confession à faire je
vais tenter d'expliquer pourquoi je
pense que je suis dans une position
intéressante pour vous parler
d'adaptation aux changements
en 2015 je reçois un diagnostic
trouble de personnalité limite
conditions qui caractérisait par une
instabilité émotionnelle marquer face
aux aléas de la vie face au changement
je vous laisse imaginer qu est ce que ça
commence à peu impacté une vis dans mon
cas sa tendance à perturber mon identité
a affecté ma capacité à être resté en
relation
et ça affecte même dans certaines dans
certaines phases de ma vie ma capacité à
fonctionner dans le monde
et comme ça se guérit pas on me dit tu
dois apprendre à vivre avec
et ce qui est curieux c'est qu'un
environnement on nous dit aussi qu'on
doit s'adapter à la nouvelle réalité
climatique parce que pas de retour en
arrière possible et que ça ça va
modifier notre identité ça va affecter
nos relations et ça va affecter notre
capacité à fonctionner comme société
c'est dur en temps mais je suis quand
j'ai réussi mon diagnostic à 20 ans je
me suis dis pauvre et si je suis pour en
souffrir toute ma vie aussi abandonner
maintenant
puis en environnement comme il ya
environnementale et j'entends vraiment
souvent des choses comme mais à quoi bon
au dessus et nos comportements si les
changements sont irréversibles
donc je vous comprends si vous vous
sentez comme ça on se protège c'est
quelque chose qui nous dépasse
mais voici une première leçon
depuis que j'ai appris à travailler avec
mes émotions et non contre elle je
m'adapte chaque jour aux nouvelles
réalités que la vue m'amène puis ça
bâtiment résilience
voici une deuxième leçon
plus j'ai tendance à résister mes
émotions puis j'ai tendance à éviter le
changement
puis ça me ravit en pleine face et plus
ça me fragilise faso reste
donc si vous voulez changer une
situation environnementale qui vous
dérange qui vous préoccupe
intéressez-vous d'abord à ce qui se
passe ici
pour moi la job d'une émotion c'est de
nous déstabiliser
pour nous faire prendre conscience de
quelque chose donc le problème si jamais
nos émotions c'est ne pas comprendre
leur origine ou de pas savoir quoi en
faire
donc aujourd'hui ce que je vous propose
ce sont des repères des repères pour
qu'ils arrivent sentir envahi par ce qui
se passe parce que vous avez raison vous
vous sentez comme ça
mais avant qu'on continue ce je vous le
dis tout de suite ça va vous demander
qu'on plonge un petit peu plus profond à
l'intérieur d'elle-même pour voir qu'est
ce qui se passe présentement
et leur reste avec moi vous êtes en de
bonnes mains moi les eaux turbulentes
generix depuis longtemps
donc j'aimerais vous paraît la métaphore
du canot qui est mon point de repère
pour quand je me sens complètement
déstabilisée par les tensions de la vie
ou encore les grandes transformations
sociales écologiques qu'on traverse
comme société
alors on peut imaginer une grande
rivière qui représentent les changements
comme tel qui soit personnel ou
collectif d'ailleurs
peu importe qu'on fait la rivière coule
puis nous amène tes yeux bat
et à l'intérêt la rivière y otros
bonhomme trois personnes qui tentent de
réagir différemment face à ces
changements le et moi j'ai été dans
toutes ces personnes là et j'imagine que
vous l'avez été aussi
la première personne c'est la personne
qu'il nage à contre-courant donc moi
quand je suis dans ces situations là
cherchent beaucoup d'informations sur le
problème et ses racines j'agis au
quotidien je m'investis dans des projets
j'essaie de changer mon mode de vie
puis je finis toujours par m'épuiser
pourquoi parce que lens était de la
colère c'est des réponses parfaitement
normal et adaptatives face au changement
mais lorsqu elle persiste dans le temps
a fini par épuiser les ressources de
l'organisme et ça ça ouvre la porte à
des primes fréquente de l'inertie
d'importantes remises en question puis
dans mon coeur d'importants problèmes de
santé
et malheureusement mon corps est
tellement pas isolé à main levée qui s'y
connaît des gens qui nagent à
contre-courant sans fins face aux
changements
dans d'autres situations je suis
clairement la personne qui se laisse
porter par le courant dans la rivière
j'ai besoin à dans ces moments là d'un
détacher de ce qui se passe de minimiser
comment je me sens d'éviter les strass
les discussions sur le sujet
ce que j'ai réalisé ce qui en a ras le
souhait de l'air de l'indifférence il ya
énormément peur
les normands tristesse
une chance que nos mécanismes de défense
sont là pour nous protéger
mais ce que j'ai observé c'est que plus
je fuis
plus je paralyse
peluche fini par frapper un mur
ou pas d'une roche pour être métaphore
donc
j'ai fini par me dire bon il n'y a aucun
moyen d'en sortir il faut que je trouve
un moyen qui était plus facile de
naviguer la rivière et j'ai fini par
comprendre qu'il fallait que je remonte
dans le canot c'est que ça veut dire
être dans le canot ça veut dire être en
équilibre dynamique entre l'action et
leur peu
dans mon canot entre autres j'ai une
pagaie la bagarre représente mes outils
pour décharger mon système nerveux quand
il est en trop plein quand tu peux rien
qui fonctionne que ce soit la méditation
lors le sport des moments pas sa nature
ces outils leur permettent de calmer mon
système nerveux et de me garder disposé
à apprendre et à trouver des solutions
en fait si j'ai pas d'outil c'est comme
si en fait mon canot continue mais j'ai
aucun contrôle sur la direction qui
prend
les canaux quand elle représente le
soutien mon entourage dément communauté
titouan d'ailleurs répond à deux besoins
fondamentaux de l'être humain
particulièrement en période de crise les
besoins de sécurité et le besoin de
connexion
sans résoudre soutien suffisant est
assez diversifié
c'est comme s'il y avait des trous dans
mon canot
et dans les canaux je prend des poses
sachant que c'est nécessaire pour
stabiliser mon humeur
consolider mes apprentissages et
réajuster mes prochaines actions
les peaux sont elles mènent des actions
pour m'adapter
et en partageant la responsabilité de
l'action parce qu'on vit jamais un
changement de style
mais je m'adapte en direct peu importe
que la rivière m'amène parce que j'ai
les outils puis le soutien pour le faire
alors on va vous laisser je vais vous
présenter trop bénéfices concrets de
remonter dans votre cas nos si jamais
vous avez remarqué que vous êtes
mouillés pas mal
mais ça va aller vite donc soyez
attentifs premièrement le fait de
reconnaître vos émotions avant qu'elles
persistent ils deviennent envahissantes
vous permettre de rapidement calmée au
système nerveux ils vous rendent créatif
face à la recherche de solution est donc
de vous adapter
deuxièmement le fait de faire la classe
à vos émotions dans vos groupes sociaux
va changer la manière dont vous
communiquer en rendant plus empathique
et en faisant davantage confiance aux
autres et donc de vous adapter
troisièmement monter dans le canot le ca
va vous permettre de trouver votre rôle
est de réduire votre sentiment d'absence
au plus bas tel est votre rôle c'est de
communiquer
d'éduquer de supporter de bâtir
d'investiguer en fait peu importe vos
privilèges
vos domaines d'études vos compétences
vos forces ou même vos passions mettez
les à contribution et on va s'adapter
collectivement moi je sais une chose
c'est que nos émotions vont continuer de
nous déstabiliser jusqu'à ce qu'on
agisse pour repenser
restructurer notre monde
et comme on est la nature j'ai la
conviction qu'on a déjà tout ce qu'on a
besoin pour régénérer les systèmes
qu'ils soient à l'intérieur de nous ou à
l'extérieur de nous
parce que c'est un même monde
et je prête à dire que c'est une partie
du rôle des échos émotion que nous
montrer j'ai peut-être pas vraiment de
milieux intérieurs milieu extérieur que
c'est un même milieu qui constamment en
mouvement on est parfaitement capable de
s'adapter là dedans
alors camarades nous sommes servent à
bon port c'est ici que je vous laisse
pour continuer mon propre voyage mais
mon souhait pour la suite de votre
voyage c'est que vous repartez non pas
avec la certitude d'avoir compris vos
émotions
avec la joie de savoir que vous feront
faire quelque chose
parce qu un monde où les besoins
affectifs son centre des discussions est
certainement un monde plus résilient
pouvez vous l'imaginer comme moi
et quand vous leur imaginer pouvez vous
l'incarnez avec moi
et dans le doute ou la prochaine fois où
vous sentir emporté par le courant parce
que ça va continuer à fumer
obama tient non
[Applaudissements]